hello and welcome to this video playing
FM eraser double-oh-seven yeah can I
expand on my all-time high or will the
London system stop me we'll see I can
this is my one of my setups against this
line going for a head shot type of play
yeah I usually go a 6 was a bit too
quick bishop f aid but ok Bishop a 6 is
not not at the end of the world d6 was
hanging
I would like to go be five before I
possible so I mean trying for that okay
hmm ok i think it's it's still useful to
go to d5 yeah how to do this five and it
doesn't really doesn't really net much
that b5 moving
yeah that's that's how it is against the
London it is notoriously solid oh he's
actually doing something surprising okay
f chicks so what's the deal 94 he plays
cream to f3 this is not well i have f 5
I mean this is not totally ridiculous
but almost it's not a not a great idea
okay I don't think that not sure about
this man is he from an idea or not I
know I don't think it's particularly
dangerous can go 95
but how to how to play it in terms of
concrete moves here if i play my trading
everything is not a great idea okay one
rotate some I'm uncovered down I was
also thinking if I've might be more but
d5 is not bad for him ok let's go for
this making sure that be4 is actually
hitting something even though after a
five I could get into some issues on the
FR that looks a lot like positions from
the French defence why I got checkmated
all the time when I was still playing
the opening
okay I'd like to get rid of that be born
that's definitely a weakness wow really
why is that a good move surprising k
okay one ok I wonder ever should take on
the two one go gay and play night
against bishop here when night doesn't
doesn't get to the critical squares
quickly this is what may I don't want to
do that want to do that but I like to
trade this this is a good idea I think
check
Queen B 5 I take d21 that shouldn't be a
problem what is he doing Knight f3 maybe
I know okay let's cover all the entries
squares so that the Queen cannot enter
my position and they have a possible
Quincy for coming your Quincy for would
lead to a good ending I think if he
takes and i definitely don't mind the
Queen trade-in on general terms it's not
so easy for him not to trade this is one
of the ways to avoid the trade but now
how to do this he has to take care of
the night my night on the seven is not
great
to see 60 on f5 is a good square and
maybe I go for a drive try to go for
that yes still has some issues here too
and untangle this position
doesn't look so bad 93 yes sir oh I
didn't see that more time warning at all
so I can be happy that I didn't blunder
stuff okay the night doesn't have any
squares but the be porn is kind of
dangerous 50-something seconds this is
quite worrisome okay I'm trying to to
get to a directly yeah I think I'm
winning the pawn
oh shoot Wow
he wants to go around with the king is
right damn it I can't believe this stuff
unbelievable wow what a shot haha that's
it for the whole time and certainly in
the from a position where I should win
the game this should be a win yeah 95
and he resides of course happy six I
didn't see that one it still should be
ok I don't see it I really don't
understand why I'm losing here so how do
I do this night be a twins ok he had a
hey I prevent him to enter Wow and he's
got kinky five key music amazing stuff
amazing stuff yeah also I mean white was
channel so totally on the ropes around
here Queen a2 is strong but I think I
played it ok I think this is this is
good and be grouping the night and I
have full control over this position
Queenie one is also very strong him it
was okay it was ok I shouldn't blame
myself there that much I just have to
have to punish this this is stuffy with
the deep on 95 is the cleanest thing the
cleanest man and this should be a win
has to be it's technically still not not
trivial in blitz but it should be a win
yeah this is often not so easy playing
against those people play the London and
then just
but I mean I played reasonably quickly
it wasn't that big a deal yeah taking on
before it's just an awful move ya know
now I'm okay i think i played this okay
i just made the one mistake in the
ending the rest of us relatively ok in
terms of blitz play okay thanks for
watching